[Musique]
je me souviens je me souviens pourquoi
j'ai autant aimé the last of us non pas
pour son gameplay non non pas pour son
scénario de base
le pitch reste assez simple mais pour
son immersion l'expérience que le jeu
nous fera vivre ce sentiment de se dire
tout ça pour ça car joël à égoïstement
choisi de sauver elie et pourtant qu'est
ce qu'il a eu raison sur le moment on le
souhaitait tous je pense certains vous
diront qu'un jeu est fait pour s'amuser
se détendre doit rester friendly mais en
quoi serait ce une obligation c'est tout
l'intérêt de the last of us et notamment
avec cette partie de l'émotion une
expérience humaine dans un monde où la
société s'est effondrée ce last of us 2
est une expérience unique avec une fin
amère et une réelle prise de risque
un jeu ne doit pas se finir forcément
bien ne doit pas durer un nombre
d'heures précis pour satisfaire la
tension éphémère du joueur non le but de
cette partie 2 est de créer cette
frustration
cette haine avant de soudainement
retrouvé ce fameux sentiment du premier
opus
bref l'expérience fut très riche alors
j'ai l'impression d'être en retard par
rapport à tout le monde concernant cette
partie 2 mais on parle quand même de the
last of us j'ai pris mon temps j'ai
savouré j'ai détourné les yeux j'étais
en colère par moments mais quel épisode
je vous propose donc aujourd'hui de
refaire un trois théories sur la licence
j'ai bien conscience que les théories de
l'époque était un petit peu foireuse
mais en même temps on a fait avec ce
qu'on avait quoi bien évidemment je vous
propose des théories 100% personnelle et
subjective que j'ai imaginé et réfléchi
suite à mon expérience sur le jeu je
vous invite à mettre vos avis et vos
théories en commentaire je suis vraiment
très curieux de connaître votre ressenti
sur l'épopée de the last of est parti de
le chemin de la vengeance
l' escalade de la violence allez on y va
[Musique]
je suis obligé de commencer par elie
c'est tout de même le personnage
principal de ce second opus est la fille
de coeur de joël the last of us partie
d'eux nous a proposé une histoire plutôt
réaliste concernant la vengeance elie
suite à la mort horrible de joël a fait
une incroyable escalade de violence un
simple retour de justice car le but
était de surtout tuer abbey s'est
transformé en un massacre quasi
injustifiée au point de tout enlever
haaby excepté sa propre vie d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour me libérer maintenant
mais bordel j'en ai vu des morts
hardcore dans les jeux mais la mort de
joël est vraiment l'une des plus
marquantes auquel j'ai assisté
j'ai mis plusieurs jours à m'en remettre
bref c'est là la puissance de ce jeu le
choc de la mort de joe elle crée en nous
un sentiment de haine et de rage je
pense sincèrement qu'on avait tous envie
d'arracher habits sans se poser de
questions c'est suite à la partie où on
la joue où nous prenons conscience des
choses du contexte de ces raisons au
point même qu'à la fin du jeu et même
lors de leur combat dans le théâtre je
voulais que tout s'arrête
mais ce n'est pas ce que souhaitait elie
malgré les raisons et lee voulait rendre
justice à joël honorer sa mémoire et
tank abbie respirait encore elie avait
en elle un sentiment d'être coupable de
la mort et de ne pas avoir honoré la
mémoire de joël c'est pourquoi elie
souhaitera malgré tout aller jusqu'au
bout prendre d'énormes risques perdre
les gens qu'elle aime et sa situation à
la ferme juste par rapport à cette
vengeance
et le pire dans tout ça c'est que joël
n'aurait jamais souhaité ça puisqu'il
avait sauvé et lit car justement elle
méritait de vivre de demeurer une vie
paisible aux côtés de joël et des gens
qu'elle aime par le biais de ce mal être
cette obsession de vengeance et lee
s'est autodétruite
et a tout perdu bafouant la mémoire de
joël car elle a fait tout le contraire
de ce qu'il aurait voulu et par rapport
à elle elle n'a pas réussi à sauver joël
à temps et ne l'a pas véritablement
venger en soi comme nous le montre la
scène avec la guitare à la fin le lien
avec joël et couper la perte des deux
doigts délit est symbolique dans ce sens
où elle a tout sacrifié pour au final
tout perdre
la guitare est temps l'union symbolique
des lits et de joël et ce malgré sa mort
est rompu et ce certainement pour
toujours par rapport à la scène de fin
justement nous voyons partir et lie
laissant la ferme et la guitare derrière
elle elle est maintenant seul et le
restera sûrement que va-t-elle ferme un
retour à jackson est impossible déjà
carélie ne se sentait plus légitime de
retourner à jackson avec toute cette
histoire bien avant le passage de santa
barbara
c'est pourquoi elle vivait à la ferme
avec dina dinah qui évidemment ne peut
pas cautionner ce comportement malgré
tout l'amour qu'elle lui a donné risqué
sa vie pour la vengeance personnelle
delhi la suivre malgré le fait qu'elle
soit enceinte
dina ne peut pas compter sur quelqu'un
qui du jour au lendemain est prête à
tout abandonner et même perdre la vie
pour rien au final
elie avaient des responsabilités envers
elle et jci par rapport à tommy
également le lien est coupé puisque dans
la capacité de mener à bien la vengeance
seul et lee avait le pouvoir de
retrouver habits chose qu'elle fera mais
ne la tuera pas au final l'objectif de
tommy n'est donc pas respectée tommy qui
au début du jeu vous les sauvegarder
et la préserver a finalement souhaité
l'envoyer à l'autre bout des etats-unis
tout seul pour son désir de vengeance
alors qu'elle était dans une situation
plutôt heureuse le changement de
comportement est révélateur puis
concernant mariah et lee a détruit
beaucoup de choses par rapport à jackson
domi a perdu un oeil et presque une
jambe
jesse est mort beaucoup de personnes ont
été détruites mentalement par rapport à
cette histoire personnelle et c'est là
que pour moi le désir de rédemption
secret non pas par rapport aux autres
mais par rapport à elle même le fait
d'épargner habits à la fin nous montre
une prise de conscience un retour
d'humanité embellie elle est jeune et a
subi bon nombre d'épreuves toute sa vie
je dirais même que la vengeance envers
habits étaient également un prétexte
pour évacuer toute sa haine
elie en voulait énormément à joël pour
la fin de ce last of est un élu a fait
savoir très souvent jusqu'à même la
veille de sa mort ou joël en a carrément
pleurer et lina donc même pas pu dire au
revoir à joël et lui montrer son
affection à cause de ce secret à
l'hôpital si nous en revenons à la
rédemption aujourd'hui ely au pied du
mur se retrouvent seuls et sans raison
de vivre elle a toujours eu peur d'être
seule et pour elle sa vie n'a pas de
sens pas de direction
rien sauf pour une chose lors de son
départ de la ferme
nous voyons une luciole sur la guitare
et lee a toujours ce statut d'élu celle
qui est immunisée contre les infectés et
comme il nous l'a été prouvé dans cette
partie 2 elle est unique
le lien coupé avec joël étant
abandonnées et n'ayant plus rien à
perdre et lee pourrait essayer de
reprendre son véritable rôle la raison
de sa vie
le vaccin contre les infectés et donc
retrouver la trace des lucioles la saga
the last of us se termine toujours sur
une note de tout ça pour ça puisque dans
le premier opus joël devait tout faire
pour amener est liée aux lucioles pur
finale l'enlèvera au dernier moment
cette huître confirme ce sentiment avec
le fait d'avoir épargné habits alors que
le but était quand même de la tuer six
parties 3 il y a et on y reviendra
nous aurions ce sentiment décuplé par
rapport aux trois jeux bien évidemment
tout ceci n'est que ma vision
personnelle je le rappelle à chaque fois
mais je pense que c'est nécessaire
a vous de me dire vos idées en
commentaire
[Musique]
s'il ya bien une question difficile à
répondre c'est bien celle ci nous ne
savons pas s'il y aura un seul as tu
fait partie 3 naughty dog reste très
flou sur le sujet et de jeu vient de
sortir donc rien de surprenant mais il
faut parler du cas de habib la
conception du jeu est particulièrement
original à ce sujet eli est l'héroïne et
nous l'avons déjà côtoyé dans the last
of us premier du nom habib est temps la
tueuse de joël le portrait
d'antagonistes et dessiner
automatiquement
c'est alors dans cette expérience plutôt
amer que l' inverse se présentera à
bille est à la base victime des choix de
coeur de joël fille de gerry anderson le
seul chirurgien ayant la capacité
d'opérer elie et extraire l'antidote de
son cerveau ce dernier se fera exécuter
par joël pour sauver elie détruisant au
passage l'alliance des lucioles est en
rassembler autour de l'espoir perdu de
faire renaître la société bref habib a
tout perdu sa vengeance cervellera juste
surtout quand on voit qu'elle n'a tué
que joël l'assassin de son père
contrairement à élie qui comme je vous
l'expliquais dans son escalade de
violence a tout perdu et a tout enlevé à
abbey qui a une fois de plus épargnée et
lee mais est ce assez pour en faire le
personnage principal du possible
prochaine opus si je vous dis ça ce
n'est pas pour rien habib est un
personnage central est jouable de the
last of us 2 et lors de l'épilogué
cette dernière accompagnée de laives
réussira à joindre un camp de lucioles
en train de se reformer dans le souci du
détail
l'homme semble même surpris de tomber
sur abbey la fille du chirurgien pouvant
créer l'antidote est l'un des dirigeants
du groupe des lucioles de salt lake
bref une fois le jeu fini l'écran
d'accueil sera modifié tout le long du
jeu nous aurons un bateau flottant de
nuit dans un brouillard très épais une
fois la scène finale passer le message
et là c'est le bateau dhabi élèves
après kelly est décidé d'épargner l'ex
wolf avec l'écran d'accueil poste fin de
jeu
le bateau est maintenant à santa
catalina l'île du groupe de lucioles
avec justement le bâtiment dom et les
confirmations des créateurs si on pense
scénario naughty dog nous vend un sacré
espoir pour un avenir du côté dhabi et
de lev et dans la conception il
symbolise même la note positive de la
fin du jeu contrairement à élie où nous
sommes dans le flou total
au vu de ce que nous propose l'histoire
de la saga the last of us
les lucioles sont un groupe à part
comparé aux autres comme le wll ou
encore laisser raffit les lucioles
symbolise l'avenir ils ne sont pas dans
la guerre des clans ou de territoire
mais dans la postérité du monde
un retour à la civilisation une solution
au problème
si une suite et une fin à la saga il
doit y avoir il faudra résoudre le
paramètre cordyceps est ce que
l'humanité et trouvera une issue
ou est ce que la civilisation est
définitivement perdue elle est là la
vraie question
la saga traitons beaucoup de messages et
de sujets sociaux et humains je ne
serais pas étonné de voir dans une suite
ce genre de réflexion surtout caby n'est
pas n'importe qui même si cela n'est pas
dit explicitement abysses et qui est
elie elle sait qu'elle est immunisé et
c'est là où cela devient intéressant
le paramètre de la mort du chirurgien a
shooté en touche l'idée de retrouver
elie étant le seul à pouvoir extraire
l'antidote de son cerveau néanmoins il
est fort probable voire sûr que des
chirurgiens
il en existe d'autres et là habits devra
choisir doit-elle retrouver celle dont
elle ne voudrait jamais revoir le visage
doit-elle livrés et liquidant sa
vengeance a finalement sauvé son ennemi
ainsi que lev doit-elle faire prendre ce
risque au groupe
en cherchant une aiguille dans une botte
de foin quitte à perdre des sommes et
l'espoir
est-ce que cela mérite d'en faire un jeu
au final l'avenir dhabi élèves semble
tout tracé
si continuité il doit y avoir un
scénario de ce type permettrait de nous
poser de nouvelles questions de voir de
nouveaux environnements et possiblement
retour ultime délit plusieurs années
après s'être déchiré dans sa vengeance
aimeriez-vous 1 the last of est parti
trois dans la peau dhabi a vous de me le
dire en commentaire
[Musique]
il est vrai comme je vous le démontre
depuis le début de la vidéo il me plaît
à penser qu'une partie 3 de the last of
us verra le jour
nous y reviendrons dans une prochaine
vidéo dédiée mais partons du principe
d'une suite the last of us à 1 et 2 font
le choix de nous proposer une vision
très fataliste du monde suite à
l'effondrement de la société soit le
premier jeu était particulièrement axé
sur la menace des infectés et cette
seconde partie sur le comportement
humain laissant carrément les infectés
au second plan ils ne sont plus la
menace principale
bref tout est menaçant humains comme
affecté tout est à risque
néanmoins les messages des deux jeux ont
beau être puissant et fort en émotions
n'y aurait-il pas une solution aux
problèmes que symbolise les infectés si
la société est tombé c'est bien à cause
de ce souci alors aurons nous une
véritable conclusion c'est ici que je
m'interroge un petit peu personnellement
alors oui eli est une solution mais une
solution perdu pour le moment duo
sauvetage fait par joël et à la mort de
gerry anderson le seul chirurgien
incompétent pour extraire l'antidote du
moins le seul connu pour le moment non
aux normes
là où j'aimerais attirer votre attention
c'est sûr si la solution était ailleurs
du souvenir même relève soulève ce
raisonnement il me semble qu est-ce qu
il y a ailleurs en l'espace de deux jeux
la plupart des états unis ont été
visités de boston à pittsburgh à salt
lake ou encore seattle lille décès
raffit santa barbara et à chaque fois
c'est le même constat
alors est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
sortir des états unis surtout que dans
le détail
plus on avance dans le temps et
l'histoire et plus on se rapproche des
villes côtières et même des îles on
connaît maintenant les états unis
et aucun espoir ni a été véritablement
trouver actuellement de ce que nous
savons le cordyceps se seraient
développées dans des cultures situés en
amérique du sud
alors je ne dis pas que l'europe l'asie
ou l'afrique ne sont pas touchés
évidemment qu'avec l'import-export les
autres continents ont dû subir un
traitement similaire preuve avec la
pandémie actuelle malheureusement j'ai
envie de vous dire mais si la situation
était différente sur les autres
continents
et si des régions du monde s'en sorte et
correctement des sociétés encore actives
qui cherchent un traitement ou une
solution c'est quelque chose que l'on
retrouve chez les lucioles les lucioles
sont parmi toutes les factions tous les
groupes rencontrés les seuls qui ont la
signification d'être positif
un groupe qui souhaite amener l'espoir
la lumière et faire revivre la société
est bien et lucioles suite aux
évènements de soleil se sont regroupés
hors du pays pour aller sur l'île de
santa catalina
et même si on reste dans les états unis
le symbole est là nous sommes hors terre
néanmoins ace que naughty dog aurait
l'ambition de développer une idée
pareille bien que the last of us se veut
être une expérience réaliste
nous sommes toujours dans l'idéologie
que si l'amérique tombe tout tombe donc
promouvoir l'idée que la solution se
trouverait ailleurs serait un message
qui irait à l'encontre de ça dans tous
les cas si cela devait arriver ce serait
potentiellement compagnie dhabi élèves
nous aurions l'occasion de voir de
nouveaux environnements de nouveaux
infectés une vision encore plus réaliste
du monde
en attendant le manque d'électricité de
moyens de transport permettent de ne pas
y répondre
et puis qui sait il est fort possible qu
aucune solution existe aux yeux de
naughty dog nous arrivons maintenant à
la fin de cette vidéo j'espère de tout
coeur qu'elle vous aura plu bien
évidemment je sais que cela stoffel 7
partie 2 a divisé
je vous ai avant tout proposer
aujourd'hui ma vision et mon ressenti
personnel c'est un jeu qui m'a marqué
merci à ceux qui s'abonneront et qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et je n'aurai
qu'une chose à dire
la fin est l'histoire de the last of us
de partie 2 a beau être amer l'amertume
reste une saveur au même titre que le
sucré le salé ou encore l'acidité
c'était argot rock et que le lay en art
soit avec vous
[Musique]